there are similar anti-police proposals
all over the country including New York
City Council candidates in that case 40
or so of them Hillary Clinton's former
spokesperson also calling for police to
be defunded so is so socialist
congresswoman part of the squad
congresswoman Talib tweeting quote I
just want us to dig deeper that the
hashtag defund police movement isn't
just brushed aside the mob the media
some there they're pushing for the
police to be abolished
news story in the Atlantic reads quote
deep on the police America needs to
rethink its priorities for the whole
criminal justice system maybe they
forgot the Donald Trump did criminal
justice reform to get rid of disparate
sentencing Rolling Stone publishing a
quote practical guide to defunding the
police Cosmo
they wrote defunding the police will
actually make us safer really and look
at this in a rare moment of common sense
from the media mob you had a writer over
at box.com tweeting quote I'm sorry but
this Savalas the police seems like a
poorly thought-out idea that's gotten
popular with shocking speed after
widespread rage and condemnation from
his far-left peers guess what he was
pressured groupthink he was forced to
apologize so clearly in the new radical
far-left socialist Democratic Party it
is now officially woke to abolish the
police today Byron York he brought up a
really good point in his tweet writing
quote well maybe it's time for some
enterprising blue state municipality to
go bold and eliminate its police force
let's see what happens
comrade de Blasio how about we'll start
with you how about you give the up the
entire Police Department in New York
give them well two weeks paid leave
including by the way the armed police
officers protecting you and your family
every day and after all black lives
matter they have already promised
they're gonna fill the void that they
will patrol the streets armed militias
if you want to call it armed peace
officers really the same black lives
matter group that frequently is called
for violence against the police take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't then President Obama meet with
some of the radicals and some of these
groups now as you're watching tonight
ask yourself this question how do you
feel are you comfortable with the police
being replaced by let's say militias
like black lives matters and others
well according to Gallup well we have
that answer it's a resounding no recent
polls showing that a majority vast
majority of Americans trust the police
in fact according to Gallup only the
police the military small businesses
received a net positive favorability
rating and just for the record the mob
and the media politicians they had the
highest net negative ratings still some
far-left mayors governors they are ready
willing to dismantle the police our
first line of defense even the michigan
governor that's governor shut down
Whitmer said that she understands the
sentiment behind the movement and
governor shutdown he used to use the
police to enforce her over the top
absolutely obscene lockdown orders
during the pandemic well guess what
today she violated her own social
distancing orders she took part in a
protest remember she outlawed lawn
mowing and for shut down Whitmer many
other Democrats the rules don't apply to
them they'll have you arrested for going
to church or if you have an a funeral
even though you wear a mass to New York
but then they'll participate in protests
with zero social distancing they'll
disband the police force all while they
remain safe and sound of course they
have their armed guards they have their
high walls security and guess what
they'll let businesses get looted burned
to the ground all while continuing to
take their paycheck by the way that goes
the same for Nancy Pelosi she says we
need proxy voting and mail-in ballots
for people's health and safety in
November so much is on the line can't
have Congress men and women voting in
person must all do it by mail well
ultimately it's going to come down to
one very simple question do you want
jobs or you like this new mob rule